Brandon is with us in Atlanta Georgia hi
Brandon how are you hey Dave good man
thanks for having me on your show
absolutely my honor how can I help
hey Dave my goal is to pay off my
mortgage as fast as possible
I know I'll follow a lot of your videos
and kind of your tips and tricks on how
to get out of debt and you know I've got
a vehicle or got two vehicles currently
paying off that I am should have paid
off here in the next few months after
that I wanted to focus more on my
mortgage and I've kind of been doing it
out of order up and focusing more on my
mortgage than my vehicles but I've kind
of switched gears and backtrack a little
bit but I've been looking online and
listening to folks primarily folks with
real estate investors and they are
talking about alternative ways to pay a
mortgage and one of those ways is to
take out a home equity line of credit
pay a lump sum towards the principle of
the mortgage and essentially use the
home equity line of credit as as your
cash and pay that off with your entire
paycheck month-over-month
now that's one that's not one that
investors it's a multi-level scam okay
they want to sell you a piece of
software to help you do this and the
whole thing is built on this fallacy
that somehow that a mortgage of the way
they calculate mortgage interest what
type of mortgage do you have FHA VA
conventional yeah they came on the page
a long okay it's calculated like simple
interest once a month and so all these
games and gyrations that you're playing
do absolutely nothing with this stuff
the only thing the only thing it does is
give them thirty four hundred bucks for
a piece of software for this multi-level
scam those are not real estate investors
dude real estate investors understand
that principle reduction is how
mortgages are paid off so here's the way
it works okay you ever looked at an
amateur ization schedule yes yeah I
pulled up my land amortization schedule
actually I'll happen as is calculating
it what happens is it what your interest
rate 3.25 okay
take that and divide it by 12 okay and
that is your monthly interest rate point
two seven okay
and so point two seven is going to be
charged on the outstanding balance that
month that's how simple interest is
calculated technically a mortgage is not
simple interest but the way principle
reduction works on the FHA loan is if
you pay ten thousand dollars on your FHA
loan it slides you down the ammeter
ization scheduled to the new loan
balance and the point two seven percent
interest is charged that month on the
new loan balance and so it has the exact
same mathematical effect as if it were
calculated as simple interest and so all
the gyration of jumping back and forth
in and out of a home equity loan does
absolutely nothing mathematically it's a
complete scale and I certainly had a
feeling there was something fishy about
it it seemed too good to be true that's
why I wanted to come on and talk to you
about it you know this I appreciate your
answer the point is that their theory is
is if you use instead of using your
money to live on you use a home equity
loan right and you use your money and
throw it at the mortgage right that's
the idea but now we've got a debt over
here on a home equity loan which is
usually a higher interest rate in a
variable interest rate too by the way
okay but but we turn to pay it back off
next month and so all we're doing is
just moving the P around under the shell
the P is still there and the piece
called principle so no don't do that
dude just light into that mortgage when
it's time so let's get this stuff in the
right order here finish these cars off
get your emergency fund in place get
your home equity loan if it's less than
half your annual income knocked out when
you're knocking out your cars if you are
if you don't have a home equity loan
because you were just discussing one for
purposes of this then we don't worry
about that your your mortgages baby step
six you get your house paid off inside
of ten years from the time you started
this process and you are on track to be
an average millionaire you get paid off
faster than that you're on track to be
an above average millionaire